[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and today we have our
ask an expert segment where we have
kevin a real estate agent
and he's my personal real estate agent
helped me buy
two houses sell one in the process of
selling the other
i wanted you to help me with the vegas
home but that doesn't work like that
right it's like you have to have a
license for each state you do
yeah so we're specifically licensed just
in the states we want to operate i mean
there are some agents that have
multiple licenses but because you lack a
license in nevada
are you confused when you look at their
properties are you like what is it
[Laughter]
pricing yes compared to california do
the pricing surprise
you because it's so much cheaper it is a
lot cheaper out there
a lot cheaper i mean it's it's nuts what
what you can buy over there compared to
what you can buy over here yeah i was
looking at
the houses and i was like yo in
california this would be like 5 million
but it's like
900 000 or something
and lifestyles is not too different over
there yeah right
yeah i mean the weather to me it's still
like it's like riverside
yeah i mean like after you leave the
beach
pretty much from downtown until
i don't know [ __ ] colorado or some
[ __ ] or like or no it's really cold
there but like maybe all the way up
until nevada it's like roughly
like the same temperature yeah i mean
their summers are actually not that bad
because we were there
probably like at the end of summer right
and it was like 110
we were looking at houses but it was
like 114 over here it was 114 here but
it's
drier over there i think it's the drier
part that kills me
it kills you i like the dryer part i
like it because you're not like beating
with sweat
yeah the humidity you're just like
drenched after a day i get dehydrated
my lungs hurt man anyways um so i'm
probably the
i never bought a home it's funny because
i've pitched in in investment properties
before i even owned my own place
yeah but like kind of like all right
there's a process to buying a used car
right like you want to make sure that
things are okay or whatever
most homes are used homes yeah so like
what are the right things that i should
be asking
when i purchase a home like like history
and all that stuff yeah like what do you
look for
i really look for the condition of the
property right
um so like maybe say let's say
electrical
right if electrical panels are old uh
like plumbing like sort of the actual
breakers like you go and look at that
yeah like to see what the age because
you know here in california especially
in
l.a a lot of the homes are probably
built as early as the 20s and you know
they can go up to easily to the 60s
right yeah so there's a lot of i mean
these houses are
approaching 100 years right so much
history
there's a lot of things whether people
have done over time or they have not
done overtime right it doesn't
necessarily mean that the house is bad
but the one thing that you kind of want
to look for in the future
is you know this could probably go out
when you own it right
so do you have the money to replace it
when it happens and how much is that
roughly going to cost
right because you don't want to spend
all your money into a property
something goes wrong and you can't even
fix it and this is the most important
thing that you own
right so those things are definitely
things that you should look at
right of course in the escrow process
you would want to try to negotiate that
but given as crazy as the market is
right now you might not be able to
negotiate that
so knowing the true condition of the
home is probably one of the
biggest things what are the conditions
so electrical like it's plumbing
electrical
plumbing roof right so like racks
rats could be one termites could be
another one how do you find the rats to
put some cheese out and see if anything
you'll find out because they got
droppings all over the place oh
[ __ ] yeah rat [ __ ] so you'll find you'll
find it through that usually in the
attic and stuff or like underneath the
house but
all of those major i always say the
major components right so electrical
foundation plumbing roof those are how
do you tell the roof though
unless it's like raining you would
either want i mean the inspector
your general home inspector is going to
be able to tell you and if they're like
yeah we see
signs of leaks or there's active leaks
right
he'll he'll note that out and then you
might want to bring in that expert to
come in
right the roofer to come in and say okay
this is the condition or this is why
you're getting leaks because
they know what to look for a lot of
people like to go off of
when the roof was last done too right
like how many years ago was that yeah
but
you know depending on how long people
have owned it some people have no idea
yeah right
so i always say don't rely everything on
what the seller is telling you you want
to make sure that
you know it you get somebody to give you
your own opinion do you
uh should you be like looking for homes
with an inspector then or should you
like find one you like first and then
bring that guy in yeah you want to find
a home first because bringing inspector
out it's going to cost you all right
yeah
you might have to go look at 20 homes
before you even get one into escrow so
that's
it's going to cost you a lot i had an
inspector and he missed something
and then like we have like um like an
electrical problem in our kitchen
yeah that he totally lift on yeah what
was the electrical problem
the the switch like um the the safety
switch thing
takes the whole wall down power wise oh
the gfc
gfci so i have to constantly press that
thing if i want to use like the
microwave yeah so
i always tell people when you do a home
inspection
he's not going to be perfect right
because literally he's in this house
for what two to three hours at most he's
not going to find everything
right so that's what we'll consider it's
a small thing because you could probably
get that fixed pretty easy with the
electrician
you put like a bigger breaker or
something yeah or maybe it's just the
outlet that's kind of
a little fickle or something at the
breaker or something maybe
at the plug itself um i always say with
the general inspection what you're
really looking out for are the major
components so that roof the electrical
like when i talk about electrical i'm
talking about
like is this electrical from the 1900s
knob in two right or knobbing tubes
yeah it's basically they have like the
literally these knobs and tubes up in
the attic that will run
um and they're like hot wires and you it
could be
flammable oh because you've got
insulation up there and everything like
that and it's like
edison level [ __ ] huh damn
or the electrical panel itself right is
it like outdated because
we use a lot more electricity in today's
world compared to somebody
back in 1920 when what do they have just
the light bulbs that they're
you know providing electricity to now we
got computers we got refrigerators we
got all these other christmas lights
what did they do for christmas lights
back then i think candles
so there's homes that have electrical in
like the 20s
and they've never been updated like in
l.a correct wow
yeah my mom's house in monterey park i
remember when we first looked at that
because it was the older home
each room only had one socket
like you know one plug-in yeah when was
it built like in the 30s or something
i don't know maybe like 50s but uh
now like if you go to any modern home
there's like a socket on every single
wall
and usbs that's what's crazy is later on
it'll be like oh this one doesn't have
usb that's so weird yeah
but yeah those are the things that you
probably really want to load it's really
the condition of the house right like
you know these older homes does it have
is it earthquake retrofitted right
was it bolted for for earthquakes right
some of them
aren't so yeah your house could fall
apart possibly if the big one hits who
knows
but if a house has been built from like
the 20s there's got to be someone that
died in there
there's got to be that would be the
first thing i asked how many ghosts is
in this [ __ ]
i'm going to find my discount so the
real like the actual question on the
disclosures is just within the past
three years
oh they can't tell you so there's a lot
of haunted houses here man it could be
it could be because we can only go back
so far what if there's like a vicious
brutal killing well uh google hopefully
that
you can find it on but you don't have to
disclose that though after three years
three years the specific things
but ghosts last longer than that dude
but if you
are if you are encountering ghosts that
you see that that's probably something
that you would want to
in the discover i see ghost here right
can you do that like in during escrow
right like let's say you do run into a
[ __ ] ghost and you're just like
man i can't buy this house man there's a
ghost in there dude
yeah you can do that i mean it's all
within your your uh
well you think they'll take it though
they'll be like nah that's not gonna
work that's not gonna fly in court dude
yeah like let's say wells fargo is
banking you
he's like nah dude you gotta buy this
house are they gonna let you bounce out
of escrow because you saw a ghost what's
the half-life on ghosts
because people are still seeing like
civil war ghosts right but nobody sees
like old roman warrior ghosts
so there's got to be some kind of maybe
because they're in italy oh [ __ ]
my bad that's geography yeah maybe they
can't come to america because
no i think ghosts get on ships though
and come over here all the time you
think they stole away i think they stole
away on the show
they're like little rats huh bringing
over the black plague exactly
i don't know man that's kind of what i
always worry about too because it's a
used house right
and then see i live in the garage and i
know that there would know
maybe some car crushed a man and he died
in there but still
you know do you tell girls you live in
the garage i think they like it more
than like you do
that's different you know progressive
yeah
i'm a minimalist ooh it's so cool these
days right
but yeah i'm always worried about like
when i move into a place
for some reason apartments don't creep
me out but it's
like a single family like new like a
older home i'm just like
somebody [ __ ] died in here or
something man there's something going on
i feel a lot of houses have uh you get
pies yeah energy
right like there's definitely houses you
walk into you're like
this is pretty depressing i know i don't
think this is it right but then you walk
into some house and you're like oh this
is amazing you ever walk into a house
where you feel depressed but then the
buyer is like
oh yeah and you're like okay people
are are you sure about that i mean i'll
point it out right yeah
it's not like i'm not gonna like not
tell them yeah i'll definitely point it
out and like
you sure and they'll be like yes are you
sure sure
and they'll be like yes i'm like okay
well today's video is brought to you by
upstart upstart is the fast and easy way
to get a personal loan to pay off your
debt
all online and i personally wish i had
something exactly like this and i knew
about it several years ago
when i went ahead and went crazy with
crypto
shopping baby and i bet there's a lot of
people doing that right now
trying to make millions of dollars on
crypto and they're like
yo oh no you know what i don't have any
more money in the bank account and i
have all these credit card bills and i
have all this stuff
i wasn't even thinking about so uh i
ended up having to take out a personal
loan
and the rates were not the greatest
and if i knew that upstart existed
i probably would have been in a better
situation
yeah what's dope about upstart is that
it's a five
minute online rate check and you can see
your rate up front
for loans from one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars there's times where i
try to get a loan and you know just
talking to a loan officer might take a
week or two
and you're like [ __ ] i need this loan
now so that's what's really cool about
upstart upstart also finds smarter rates
with trusted partners because they
assess
more than just your credit score and you
can get approved the same day and
receive
funds as fast as one business day
so if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start with
upstart that's right so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record don't forget to use our
url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com off the record
have you ever had uh any clients like be
like i don't want this house man it's
haunted like i need to get the [ __ ] out
of here
after they bought it yeah no i haven't
had that but
definitely i feel vibes in certain
properties that we've gone
into yeah the vibes feel better the
cheaper
the process yeah for sure for me because
i remember vegas or like every house had
a great vibe
you're like this one's hotter you're
like i don't know about that but it's
like 200 000 and you're like
oh what ghost i could live with ghosts i
only got bad vibes when i'm like there's
no pool
i think i'm the same way man if i got a
great discount i think
my fear of the ghosts will go away i'd
be like [ __ ] we're [ __ ] roommates i
don't care
get some sage yeah man it's worth the
discount
so what are the things you look for
those are the main ones community
right um wherever you're gonna live
that's basically we're going to be
at most of the time so you definitely
want to make sure you
like the community a lot of people buy
for school districts as well too so make
sure you like the school districts
because usually by the time you get to
purchasing a house the next thing that
usually happens is
little babies yeah afterwards so those
little babies got to go
somewhere for school eventually is that
the longest people usually stay
is like when they kind of start popping
out kids
uh depending on where they're at in
their life cycle so there's you know a
lot of people
i always say when people first get
married that's like usually the first
time that they'll start to look for the
house so
they'll envision that 30-year house like
we want the kids we want that but they
can't afford it yet right so
you might want to just buy that starter
home first and then once you buy that
starter home you actually have the kid
then move up to the next to the next one
right
but is that the longest that people stay
i think the generation before us
definitely stayed in houses a lot longer
than
this generation right because if you
probably go look at all your parents
they probably still live in the same
house
that they probably originally bought do
you have to disclose if like they shot
like a lot of porn in the house
you should like all the homes
there was an attorney that told me about
a story that his
uh they had a case where um they sold
the property a client sold the property
and they didn't know that there was a
bunch of porn being shot in the house
did they do like a pure space airbnb
situation and porn was being shot there
i have no idea what what the actual it
was before airbnb though
so definitely not that but the buyer
didn't know that there was porn
buyer did it but they found out about it
what's wrong
the wife was just like appalled about
the situation she was like
there and there and like she couldn't
she didn't get horny huh
i always say you want to disclose any if
you were on the other side and you found
out about it
are you okay with it right if you're not
or if you even just question
it a little bit disclose it damn it's
crazy how they say
one man's trash is another man's
treasure because i would have paid more
money you know that i'll be like you're
telling me that this is that scene where
they had jenna james
oh my god this is anal angels 14 no
wait a minute there's [ __ ] juice all
over these walls
are you telling me that this is where he
sprayed the [ __ ] nut
oh my god it's not how you mark it right
she cleaned yourself off in this shower
the thing that sucks though is the same
furniture isn't there though so it's all
different i'm sure you can ask about it
yeah you can negotiate they went to the
wrong market man what they should have
done
is sold this to the like a porn
convention
would you like to buy the famous anal
angels
you know [ __ ] house or whatever you
know they'll be like oh my god i'd buy
that house
niche market wrong customer base dude
what is another
way you can like make sure that you're
not buying something that's gonna fall
apart on you like the lemon version of
the house yeah
the lemon version of the house probably
not making an offer with no
contingencies that's
that's for sure right because you have
no idea what you're buying a lot of
people do also want to buy houses like
everybody wants that deal right so
they're like you know where the
foreclosures where the short sales
um so you can buy properties at auction
we haven't seen it yet because the
market hasn't really tipped but
eventually that probably will come back
into the marketplace
um and they'll sell properties at the
courthouses because people can't
pay their mortgages anymore i mean that
is another example where we don't have
the experience or the know-how or the
extra capital
definitely don't get into something like
that why because are they like as is
sales when you buy from the banks or the
court yeah
you can't even you can a lot of times
you can't even see the property that's
like a storage wars you can't even
see it correct so you really have no
idea but people always come
like we want the best deal and how do we
do this i'm like you can do it
but like if you don't know how to fix it
or you don't have the money to fix it
what's what's the good deal gonna do do
they know
like anything like oh this is a house
like let's say the police department was
selling some houses because like they're
like this was a math house and then
there's like 15 machine gun bullets all
over there was a raid
do they do you know these details or
like you buy a house and you go there
and you're like half of the house is
burnt down what the [ __ ] yeah
all the controls so the difference
between that is
you know who's going to own it right at
that point which is the bank
and the bank is literally just a
corporation right so
the bank has no idea they have no they
know nothing about the property except
for
maybe the address and like the
characteristics of the process
can we look at it a lot of times you you
wouldn't even be able to sometimes they
will allow you to
essentially even want to buy it because
it's so cheap some of them i'll see like
even in l.a would be like 40 grand right
yeah
so it's like do you want to take that
gamble do you want to just put up the 40
grand
to buy the whole house or but you don't
know bigger the risk the bigger reward
right but sometimes it may not be worth
it is it like an auction auction where
you have a guy go 45 45 you do
have you guys purchased uh your uh any
homes like that
i haven't actually purchased but i've
gone to a few
like they did they used to do it at like
hotels um like in the big like banquet
halls
you know they had it all set up you sign
in you get like a card and they're like
these are the properties that are coming
out and they literally have that guy up
there how come you don't buy one of
those guys
i've tried i looked into it yeah right
um but it is very
it is very complicated so i mean it
really depends on how much time and
energy you want to spend into it
because you really need to do your
homework before you get in there and
even the homework that you do on the
properties
like the bank can take it off the day up
so you can literally go to the site
thinking you're gonna auction on this
property that you've done research on
and they say hey you know we've worked
out a deal with uh with the person that
has the loan on
on it or they're prolonging it and
they're pushing it to another date so
like hey they got their house back and
you're like [ __ ] yeah so it's a lot of
it could be very possible yeah i wanted
it so
that takes up a lot of time that would
take away from what i do
right so that's not my main focus focus
of business
there are certain people that do that
right i want to be the guy that turns
trash into treasures
i guess i'll have to be at the auction
to be like 20
20 000 and i'm like yes and i go there
and it's like
nothing but land and some burnt posts
and a chimney
a lot in bird post i know and i'm just
like oh man this was a part of that fire
we just had
dude that would suck speaking of like a
community in like the neighborhood
i remember we were seeing this house in
south pasadena
and a lot of the homes in south pasadena
are older because it's just they were
just built long time ago
but like when me and geo and i don't
know
if we brought taiko or not but we could
really envision like walking up to
school because it's right down the
street from the school and it looked
really really good
and like all the neighbors seemed like
really quiet and peaceful
but then we brought in um my friend's
uncle who's a contractor
because he was like don't worry about
the house is old i can make
make it look like anything but i think
when we got there and he started
knocking on the walls
he was like asbestos or like oh yeah or
like
i remember that it was like via del rey
or something yeah it was like some like
he was like oh [ __ ] like if you want to
remodel this house
it's going to be it was going to be like
twice the budget because you have to
take down
all the walls now because they're all
built before a certain amount of does
that mean there's like
toxic chemicals in it there could have
been yeah there could be depending on
like when
it was built and stuff like that why do
people like so much toxic material back
then
they probably didn't know let me put
just mercury in the walls and [ __ ] you
know
deform the [ __ ] out of my yeah but
sometimes like it does take like a whole
team
to go and make sure if the house is
right for you because we were looking
specifically in that area
inventory was even lower we found the
community that we really liked
but then the house itself it was just
going to be way more if we wanted to
remodel and make it look modern correct
and i think that goes back to like that
original point was you know if you had
some if you don't know the other person
on the other side or you just go direct
to the agent that's representing the
seller they might not tell you something
like that
right yeah and then you get into it you
purchase something you're like okay this
is what i want to do but
it's like three times what i wanted to
do now you're gonna be stuck in a house
that you're not happy with
right so you do want somebody to help
you navigate through that whole process
i think a lot of people look like well
everything is online right i can go to
zillow i can go to redfin i can find
that
do you hate zillow i hate zelda yeah why
agents hate zil a little more than cab
drivers hate uber
oh it's probably red thin [ __ ] redfin
it's probably pretty close actually
really i would think so
what's bad about zillow i always say
zillow's a good starting point right but
it's not neces but
people believe in zillow so adamantly
like oh no zillow says this and this is
oh like they see they see the price
that's what the zillow exactly
is the estimate's all [ __ ] up on
zillow though well but some people like
they're like no this is what zillow says
that's true and i'm like
uh it's it's not right um
and the other thing that i don't like
about zillow but zillow's gonna change
too so zillow is
actually turning into a brokerage so how
that all formulates uh
yeah you could buy a house on like
brazil zillow will buy houses from
from people uh i had a i had a client
just recently so they did the zillow
offers
a zilla offered them 600 000 like no
contingency this is
the price just like carmax yeah pretty
much and
we ended i was like well what are they
offering he's like 600 000 he's like
what do you think you can get me
and i had a range and we actually
outperformed what i thought we could
even get we basically netted him
almost 60 000 more than what what zillow
offered
right but some people don't mind that
they don't want to deal with the hassle
of getting the property ready
talking to kevin yeah talking to me like
he's gonna screw me over
right um so there's all those things
that some people are like forget i'll
just
i'll just let it go even though they
know it's at a discount
but the other thing is a lot of people
search on zillow and they see these
pre-foreclosed
homes right um that's one of the most
difficult things because
it looks like it's for sale but all
zillow does is it tracks because
whenever a property goes into what we
call pre-foreclosures basically the
person didn't make their payments on
their mortgage that's the first thing
then the bank sends what we call notice
of default it basically means hey you
didn't make your payments on the
property
you've fallen behind you need to make up
this is the penalty and so forth
then they will give them usually 90 days
if they don't cure that
then the next step would be a notice of
trustee sale
right so that's another notice and all
this gets recorded at the county
recorders
so zillow has a program where they pick
all this stuff up and when it when it
picks up
they throw it out and say hey this is a
pre-foreclosed home but it doesn't
necessarily
can't get their [ __ ] together exactly
but people think
that it's for sale when it's really not
for sale
right so that throws this huge confusion
for for us because they're like hey i
saw this on zillow
can we go see it and i'm like looking on
my system it's not for sale then i go on
zillow and i look at it like okay it's a
pre-foreclosed home
this is a situation i gotta explain that
like 50 times
throughout oh man yeah they still own
their own house and you just have to
explain to us dude i'm sorry damn
but yeah so that's that's the one big
reason why
zillow's not always the most accurate
what they portray and what's actual so
it doesn't help educate the public it
confuses the public correct
if they don't understand like what
pre-foreclosure is and all these other
things because you even looked i
remember on
zillion you would send me property like
hey there's this property in pasadena
but it shows south uh south pass schools
and i'm like
that's still pasadena schools right so
what comes up on there isn't necessarily
always 100
accurate so that's that's the
difficult part it's because it's adding
an extra layer for us
yeah because that's like a big theme
with like when you're shopping for
homes to be in the right school district
if the homes are in a really good school
district usually paying a premium for
that
yeah and then so when i saw that this
home was technically in this city
but it qualified for this school
district so i don't have to pay the
premium i'm like oh [ __ ] that's dope
correct but then zillow also
isn't the authority in the jurisdiction
of the schools
they're just kind of estimating
geographically yeah whatever's closest
about oh should probably go to that
school they don't
actually narrow it down like this is
exact this is why i'm a red fan guy
i'm just a craigslist dude
you